let's discuss remember the Minutemen
maybe this is a good way to start it
some people in our audience might be too
young to remember the Minutemen when
george w bush was president the
Minutemen
organized themselves to extrajudicial et
extrajudicial ii monitor the us-mexico
border what I mean by that is they would
they would show up at the border in
California and Arizona and I'm picturing
the map New Mexico and Texas on the
us-mexico border in the southwest of the
United States they would show up with
rifles and handguns and they were there
they said to help stop illegal border
crossings I know several Border Patrol
agents and they told me that they found
the Minutemen to be a gigantic and total
nuisance rather than any kind of help
there were like eight Fiasco's involving
these Minutemen I'm not going to go
through them here but long story short
the group ended up splintering into
several subgroups some of those groups
ended up conflicting with each other
some of them have still been patrolling
the border in smaller numbers I know you
know where the story is going we now
have the trumpets FoxNews fear-mongering
around the Latino middle Easterner
invasion that they believe is coming to
the us-mexico border so this has now
reactivated a lot of these different
gun-toting militia groups to head to the
border to I guess as they see it protect
us most of them realize that they are
not law enforcement so they can't work
in a law enforcement capacity since
they're just mostly dudes with guns but
they are saying we are going to be there
to observe and report what it is that we
see I want you to consider something I
told you in the last story that the
Pentagon advised the Trump
administration that the immigrant
Caravan itself is no invasion and poses
no threat but the military is warning
military commanders who will be down at
the border that the armed militias
turned vigilantes are actually what they
need to be aware of ok understand this
the military is being warned more about
the militias
thing of the border then the immigrants
they're supposed to be there to protect
us against this is terrifying
and I know that I live in Massachusetts
right I'm sort of insulated from a lot
of this political nonsense but this is a
nightmare
you have xenophobic armed right-wingers
going to play army at the border
alongside border patrol and actual
military troops who shouldn't even be
there and maybe they're in violation of
the law because the military is not
supposed to be used to serve a law
enforcement function and what are they
even going to do for the weeks before
the caravan is even slated to arrive at
the border anyway because it's going to
be weeks and I am Telling You today
whatever the date is today the day
before the election mark my words if the
militias and the military and Border
Patrol are still there if and when the
caravan finally does arrive with as few
as a couple hundred people weeks or
months from now there will be violence
but it will not be because of the
immigrants because this is straight up
dark ages pre-enlightenment I mean I
mean I don't even sure what words to
apply to this this is retrograde
behavior it's disgusting and it is all
ginned up in this xenophobic placating
of the white the white separatists and
the white nationalists that we have been
talking about I hope it doesn't get ugly
and this is like I go back to I get
emails from people who say David why do
you want Trump to fail why do you want
the stock market to crash why do you
want the economy to be bad I don't want
any of those things believe me if you
looked at my mutual fund account from
October 2018 last month it is by orders
of magnitude the worst month that my
account has had ever not necessarily in
percentage but certainly in dollars lost
because over time ideally you have more
and more money in there so nine percent
is more and more of a loss the
last thing I want is for the stock
market to crash or for Trump to fail or
for North Korea to bomb someone just so
I can say look Trump failed I don't want
any of that stuff and there's no
evidence you can point to that suggests
that I do but when you see these
horribly misguided disastrous decisions
being made and you understand it's
obviously going to implode in their
faces to have Border Patrol and the
military and local law enforcement in
some cases and armed militias who are
often motivated by xenophobia more than
any sort of constitutional rights or
desires to maintain the rule of law and
then these immigrants show up it is a
recipe for disaster and my only hope is
that number one people don't hurt get
hurt invariably or end up hurting others
in irreversible or ways that that we
can't undo I think you know what I mean
but they've got to be held accountable
if that's what they do if you think that
this is gonna go differently I want to
hear from you make sure you follow the
show on Instagram a David Pakman show
you can follow me on instagram at david
pakman we've got behind the scenes
pictures of the studio and so much more
today's program is sponsored in part by
stamps.com
which I've been using to mail out the
david pakman show calendars that we do
and a bunch of other stuff for years at
this point almost everything now is on
demand so there's really no reason to
make all of those trips to the post
office whenever you have to mail a
letter or a package because you can get
it all on demand with stamps.com many of
you remember my stories about my
frequent trips to the post office to
mail stuff out to people in the audience
no more because now with stamps.com i
can access all those services from the
post office which are great services
from my desk 24/7 when it's convenient
for me buy and print official US postage
for any letter any package using your
own computer and printer mail carriers
will then pick it up click print email
and you're done we've been using it for
years and right now you can use the code
Pakman for a special off
including fifty five dollars in free
postage a free digital scale and a four
week trial
don't wait stamps.com before you do
anything else click the radio microphone
very important click the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
type Packman to get this deal stamps.com
radio microphone enter Pakman